♪ ♪
>> Tucker: TIME NOW FOR "FINAL
EXAM," WHERE WE SEE WHICH
FIGURES IN THE NEWS HAVE BEEN
VANQUISHED, BRIAN KILMEADE,
PETER DOOCY, GILLIAN TURNER, AND
OUR FRIEND GRIFF JENKINS.
PALAFOX POLITICS EDITOR
CHRIS STIREWALT, IS HE UP TO THE
TASK?
IS CHRIS STIREWALT, IT'S THE
COVETED --
SHANNON WILL GET THE
AIRPLANE-SIZED BOTTLE OF GREEN
CHAMPAGNE.
>> I LOVE IT.
HANDS ON BUZZERS.
I'M GOING TO ASK THE QUESTION.
IT IS WINTER.
THE EAST COAST IS GETTING
POUNDED BY AN EXTREME WEATHER
SYSTEM WHICH IS UNLEASHING
BLIZZARD-LIKE CONDITIONS.
THE NAME OF THIS WEATHER SYSTEM
IS CHARACTERISTICALLY
OVERHEATED, AS IS OFTEN THE CASE
AND METEOROLOGY.
WHAT ARE THE CONGRESS WEATHER
SYSTEM?
SHANNON BREAM?
>> GRAYSON.
>> Tucker: GRAYSON IS YOUR
ANSWER?
>> THAT IS THE NAME OF THE
STORM, RIGHT?
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO GO TO THE
IS BEING CALLED A BOMB CYCLONE.
>> BREAKING NEWS, A WINTER BOMB
CYCLONE, AS IT IS CALLED,
BEARING DOWN ON 40 MILLION
PEOPLE.
>> A SO-CALLED BOMB CYCLE AND
TAKING AIM.
>> DON'T GIVE ME THAT.
>> THAT BOMB CYCLONE.
>> I DIDN'T COIN THE PHRASE
BOMB CYCLONE.
SOMETHING CALLED FIVE
BOMBOGENESIS.
>> Tucker: THIS MAY BE A CASE
OF YOU KNOWING TOO MUCH.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO GO WITH
THE COLLOQUIAL TERM.
>> I AM OUT.
WHAT IS IT CALLED.
>> Tucker: SORRY.
>> NOW I SEE.
>> Tucker: YOU GOT FOUR MORE
QUESTIONS.
FIRST RESPONDERS RUSHED TO THE
PROPERTY OF THE PRESIDENT WHOSE
PROPERTY WAS AT?
>> BILL AND HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Tucker: WAS AT BILL AND
HILLARY CLINTON?
>> FIREFIGHTERS RUSHING TO THE
HOME OF BILL AND
HILLARY CLINTON, A SMALL FIRE
BREAKING OUT ON THE SECOND FLOOR
OF A SECRET SERVICE FACILITY.
>> BUT THE HOUSE IS ACTUALLY
KNOWN AS GRAYSON.
[LAUGHTER]
>> IT IS THE BOMBA FLY
>> IT IS THE BOMBA FLY B
>> IT IS THE BOMBA FLY I
>> IT IS THE BOMBA FLY S
>> IT IS THE BOMBA FLY .
I CAN'T COME BACK.
>> Tucker: AT CNN UNDER FIRE
SHANNON BREAM?
>> EIGHT BONG >> Tucker: A
BONG SAYS SHANNON BREAM.
IS SHE AN EXPERT?
I THOUGHT MAYBE I WOULD BRING A
GAS MASK WITH US SO I WOULDN'T
>> A BONG.
OF COURSE, THEY COULDN'T STAND
TO SEE A BONG THEY DIDN'T HAVE
ANY CANNABIS IN IT.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS WHAT A GAS
MASK IS USED FOR.
BUT, WOW.
EVERYBODY.
>> Tucker: SO THE ANSWER WE
WERE LOOKING FOR WAS GAS MASK,
BUT AS OUR JUDGES JUST POINTED
OUT, IT WAS A BONG.
>> CALLED GRAYSON.
>> Tucker: BACK AT 1-1.
OKAY.
NEXT QUESTION.
1-0, BECAUSE I GOT RIPPED
OFF.
>> Tucker: WHICH CELEBRITY
HOST IS NOW IN A FEUD WITH ERIC
TRUMP AFTER ERIC TRUMP SUGGESTED
SHE WAS A MEMBER OF --
CELEBRITY TELEVISION HOST IN A
FEUD WITH ERIC TRUMP, HE SAYS
SHE IS A MEMBER OF THE DEEP
STATE.
SHE IS A COMEDIAN, A COMEDIENNE.
SOME PEOPLE CALL HER THE NEW
OPRAH.
I DON'T.
>> WHOOPI GOLDBERG?
>> Tucker: IS IT WILL BE
GOLDBERG?
>> MY NAME IS TRENDING BECAUSE
OF THIS.
ERIC TRUMP SUGGESTS THAT ON THE
APPARENTLY I AM PART OF A SECRET
CONSPIRACY.
IT IS THE CRAZIEST THING I HAVE
SEEN ALL WEEK.
I SAW THE MOVIE WITH THE LADY
HAVING SEX WITH A FISH.
THIS IS CRAZIER.
>> I DIDN'T SEE THAT.
>> Tucker: FINAL QUESTION.
THIS WILL BE A FAST ONE, SO BE
READY, OKAY?
YOU MAY KNOW THE ANSWER.
WHICH SENATOR ANNOUNCED HE IS
RETIRING THIS YEAR, POSSIBLY
PAVING THE WAY FOR MITT ROMNEY
TO RUN FOR HIS SEAT?
>> OH!
>> Tucker: THAT CAN'T BE
RIGHT.
>> IT SENATOR GRAYSON.
>> ORRIN HATCH WILL NOT SEEK
REELECTION THIS YEAR.
THE 83-YEAR-OLD LAWMAKER FROM
UTAH ANNOUNCING HIS RETIREMENT
AFTER SERVING SINCE 1977.
>> 1977?
WERE YOU ALIVE THEM?
>> BARELY.
>> I DON'T THINK SINCE HE WAS
PULLED OFF THE COURT IN THE LATE
'70s.
NEVER SEEN A COMEBACK LIKE THAT.
SHANNON BREAM, DON'T FEEL BAD.
YOU GET OUR AIRPLANE-SIZED
CHAMPAGNE.
IT IS DELICIOUS.
CHRIS STIREWALT, YOU REALLY WERE